hey everyone
welcome
this is another book review
an exegesis where we are
drawing out the salience
that we have found in what is known as
one of the best books on spirituality of
all time
by one of the world's leading spiritual
synthesis
eckhart tolle the power of
now a guide to spiritual enlightenment
definitely one of the best books
and
every sentence does ring with truth and
power
and
eckerd's made a profound impact on my
life and
on many of the lives of
many of my friends and people around the
world so i'm looking forward to this
exegesis and also
to the impact that'll make on you and
hopefully even
you checking it out as well as
accelerating your god realization
and as we talk about on our program
there are
all of these faces
of the same one mountain and it is the
same
one end and all of the perennial wisdoms
from the spiritual traditions point to
that same thing
and you'll notice how eckert and i are
very similar
in that sense of
mapping out the different perennial
wisdoms
and then synthesizing them
into
what is really relatable and
can really be profoundly influential
all right let's dive in
in the intro resist
nothing
soft luminosity filtering through
the curtains was love itself
marveling at the beauty and aliveness of
it all
just such a simple example to start
i walked around the city in utter
amazement at the miracle of life on
earth
as if i had just been born into this
world the next five months
i lived in a state of uninterrupted deep
peace and bliss it's pretty timely
because i just had my satori
about a month ago
withdraw from identification with the
unhappy
and deeply fearful self which is
ultimately a fiction
of the mind true nature
is the ever-present i am consciousness
in its pure state prior to
identification with form
he spent almost two years sitting on
park benches in a state of the
most intense joy
i love this intro it's so good
and that's why the wisdoms that
other spiritual teachers especially of
non-duality some of the world's leading
like rupert spyra
that we've done exegesis of his books as
well
they're articulating
that perennial wisdom
that eternal awareness that is being
colored
by experience in these dream realities
you have it already you just can't feel
it because your mind is making
too much noise
calm the monkey mind
2000 years ago union
equals consciousness waves
quieting
synthesis and distillation map the most
efficient paths
the mountain faces to the one
truth mountain top
this is a big part of our
synthesis and distillation
looking forward to publishing those
additional images soon
and part of it you can get these little
sneak peeks across places like our
instagram where we post this where you
see that
you have this brown
iris and this blue iris
pair of eyes and so the pupil is the eye
of god
which is shared whereas the iris is the
coloration of experience
which is unique
super simple explain like i'm five
he kept the question and answer format
he learned and received as much in those
classes and sessions as the questioners
he combined certain types of questions
that were frequently asked into one and
extracted the essence from different
answers to form one generic answer
in the process of writing an entirely
new answer came that was more profound
or insightful than
anything i had ever uttered
the student
teaches the teacher and the teacher
teaches the student
at the same time
free yourself from enslavement to the
mind enter into this enlightened state
of consciousness and sustain it in
everyday life
he has this great pause symbol which
indicates to stop reading for a moment
become still and feel and experience the
truth
of what has just been said
it's an excellent strategy
all i can do is remind you of what you
have forgotten
living knowledge ancient and yet ever
new is then activated and released from
within
every cell of your body
don't get attached to any words they are
only stepping stones
to be left behind as quickly as possible
i've definitely noticed this to be very
profound
and true is that
we leverage the words in the
different faces
of the mountain to the one end and
then we shed the words
have a non-attachment
it's indescribable perfection
in essence there is and always has been
only
one spiritual teaching
adore that and that's what's meant by
the many paths one end
the perennial wisdom
and religions have become almost
completely obscured
by it
so religion is very much obscuring
what the mystic traditions
are pointing to and
that's why each one of the major
religions has a mystic tradition
and why the mystic traditions are the
ones that are
the favorites
across those that are truly
seeking god realization
go more deeply into what you already
have
a restatement for our time of that one
timeless spiritual teaching one
true source within
as sri aurobindo says the well of honey
under the rock i love that one it's so
good
aka the
the source that god realization
which is the nature of it
bliss peace innocence play
eternal which is under the rock
of the contracted separate
egoic entity
dissolve it and get to that well of
honey
nothing to give you and who is telling
you to look inside
this is interesting so he's referencing
that
this story where
the beggar asks a stranger to spare some
change
and then the stranger tells the beggar
what are you sitting on have you ever
looked inside
that old box and the beggar says no
what's the point there's nothing in
there and the stranger says have a look
inside
and the beggar opens the lid and he saw
the boxes filled with gold
and this is why similarly eckerd saying
i'm the stranger
who has nothing to give you and who is
telling you to look inside
simply again just the well of honey
under the rock as rumi said a diamond
necklace that is already around your
neck
yet it remains for you to recognize it
treasure within is infinitely greater
than
anything the world can offer
your true nature beyond name and form
the end of suffering
adore the teachings
of the buddha
being is the eternal ever present
one life beyond the myriad forms of life
that are subject to birth and death
being is not
only beyond but also deep within every
form
as its innermost invisible and
indestructible essence
to regain awareness of being and to
abide in that state of
feeling realization is enlightenment
and this is again what is known as the
middle path or the middle way
or the tantric path or sahaja samadhi or
the goldilocks zone
again that it is both
the formless and the form
and that's why we weave our enlightened
realization into the social fabric
enlightenment is a state of wholeness
of being at one and therefore at peace
enlightenment is not only the end of
suffering
and of continuous conflict within and
without
but also the end of the dreadful
enslavement to incessant thinking
what an incredible liberation this is
oh that monkey mind
theravada buddhism the vipassana
retreats that i sat for 10 straight days
in
complete silence no eye contact
no technology no talking
and practicing for those 10 straight
days i did that four times
that was what really eradicated the
roots of the craving and aversion of the
monkey mind
it gave me that power that focus to be
in that eternal presence it was a
massive influence
and we'll uncover this more in future
content but this is one of the things
that
the pointing out to the direct
realization of non-duality
is really profound and important yet
to be complemented by these
perennial wisdoms from the spiritual
traditions
is also really important because it's
what really
creates the ability for
the non-dual realization to land in the
essence
you believe that you are your mind
this is the delusion
can you be free of your mind whenever
you want to
have you found the off button
you are unconsciously identified with it
so you don't even know that you are its
slave
and the breath
it's the best tool that we always carry
with
us to be able to bring us into that
conscious presence
now
watch the thinker a higher level of
consciousness becomes activated
all the things that truly matter beauty
love creativity joy inner peace
arise from beyond the mind you begin to
awaken
and that's what the perennial traditions
call the witness
or the i am or the self
or in the analogies it's the ocean
that the egoic contracted sugar cube
entity dissolves into that ocean
of i am self-witness that then
becomes the observer of the
waves as experiences
and then furthermore is the realization
that
of the absolute as in even the
i am the self the observer the witness
is itself a illusion
it itself also is completely dreamed
the witness as well as the experience
that the witness is undergoing the ocean
and the waves are a dream
you can watch more of the videos on our
channel to
dive into that
be there as the witnessing presence
you are aware not only of the thought
but also of yourself
as the witness of the thought
and that's a profound step up so usually
we start with oh i am just an
a separate individual and then we
recognize that oh i'm a drop in the
ocean and that's when usually the
individual egoic entity melts into that
ocean
and that's when you recognize that you
are this
witness of the experiences
and then that last step that we just
described a little bit earlier
recognize these gaps where there's no
mind
so the pauses in the monkey mind
and that's where you'll see the witness
when these gaps occur you feel a certain
stillness and peace inside you
this is the beginning of your natural
state of felt oneness with being
which is usually obscured by the mind
with practice the sense of stillness and
peace will deepen
there is no end to its depth
constantly becoming more and more
peaceful blissful
no mind pure consciousness
directing the focus of your attention
into the now
intensely conscious of the present
moment
no mind in which you are highly alert
and aware but not thinking
again those are the gaps
that's where you can
focus in on the now as the witness
pay close attention to every step every
movement
even your breathing be totally present
one certain criterion by which you can
measure
your success in this practice the degree
of peace
that you feel within
learn to disidentify from your mind
and as you'd like to throughout go ahead
and
pause the video and
as we you know we do these exegesis
so that you can see how we drew out the
salience
of what we found most profound so if
you'd like to you can pause the video
and then also draw out what you find
most profound
and we can continue that process and we
also have some notes in the bio
as well for you to look at of some of
the profound
things that we drew out
because you are identified with it
thinking
which means you derive your sense of
self from the content and activity of
your mind
may call this the phantom self the ego
the term ego means a false self
created by unconscious identification
with the mind
to the ego the present moment hardly
exists only past and future are
considered important
that's a big key
how much time are we ruminating in the
past or the future
versus in the now
the ego reduces the present to a means
to an end
the present moment holds the key to
liberation but you cannot find the
present moment as long as you are
your mind
mind is no more than a stage in the
evolution of consciousness
we need to go on to the next stage now
enlightenment means rising above thought
you still use your thinking mind
when needed but in a much more focused
and effective way than before
you are free of the involuntary internal
dialogue
and there is inner stillness
no mind is consciousness without thought
the great scientists have reported that
their creative breakthroughs came at a
time of
mental quietude
silence
emotion literally means disturbance
latin and movere meaning to disturb
even when the sky is heavily overcast
the sun hasn't disappeared
again that very perennial analogy of the
sky
being that i am that self that witness
that observer or the sun
and then all of the clouds that come and
produce
overcast and obscure creating that egoic
contraction that then dissolves
as it pierces the veil and god
realization
recognizes the diamond necklace already
around its neck
recognizing that it is that sun that sky
that ocean that is the experiencer
of the clouds or the waves
all cravings are the mind seeking
salvation or fulfillment
in external things and in the future as
a substitute for the joy of being
just like in the parable of the prodigal
son this
going outward and then hitting a
breaking point
and then turning back and going inward
again these perennial wisdoms run
very very deep
be the buddha be the awakened one
all right consciousness the way out of
pain
the intensity of the pain depends on the
degree
of resistance to the present moment
and this in turn depends on how strongly
you are identified with your mind
the mind always seeks to deny the now
and to escape from it
the more you are identified with your
mind the more you
suffer the more you are able to honor
and accept the now
the more you are free of pain of
suffering
and free of the egoic mind
so ego is that resisting of the now
which leads to that pain and suffering
we've got to shed those egoic
onion layers of identity down to that
pure
bare empty awareness consciousness
i am-ness
make the now the primary focus of your
life
have your dwelling place in the now and
pay brief visits to past and future when
required to deal with the practical
aspects
of your life situation
surrender to what is
allow the present moment to be
the pain body wants to survive it needs
to get its food
through you
stop feeding that pain body
enter into that eternal presence
the pain body which is the dark shadow
cast by the ego
is actually afraid of the light of your
consciousness
it is afraid of being found out its
survival depends on your
unconscious identification with it
realize this truth that is make it real
in your own
experience free yourself
from that pain
be the ever alert guardian of your inner
space
unconscious implies a complete absence
of the watcher
so unconscious equals the i am sun
completely obscured by the clouds
these analogies are very powerful and
very childlike
repurpose them reuse them make it simple
the esoteric meaning of the ancient art
of alchemy
the transmutation of suffering into
consciousness
spiritual alchemy
for many women the pain body awakens
particularly at the time preceding the
menstrual flow
stay alert and present at that time and
watch whatever you feel within
the most powerful spiritual practice and
a rapid transmutation
of all past pain becomes possible
you have made an unhappy self this mind
made fiction
is who you are in that case unconscious
fear of losing your identity will create
strong resistance to any
disidentification
this is why people struggle with
shedding those onion layers because they
have become
identified with them the amkara
as it is said those ego layers of
identity on the onion
attachment attachment to those layers
shed them find someone who is intensely
conscious
be with them and join them in the state
of presence that can
help that can be helpful and will
accelerate things
your own light will quickly grow
stronger
this is critical unsubscribe to people
that don't shed that
light of bliss and peace
and subscribe to those that do
true power is within
compulsive pursuit of ego gratification
possessions
money success power recognition or
special relationship
you will know the truth of it for
yourself
you will know it at the latest when you
feel death approaching
death is a stripping away of all that is
not
you the secret of life is to die
before you die
and find that there is no
death
again in essence when that egoic
contracted entity dissolves
into the oceanic infinitude what happens
is you die before you die because you
recognize
the non-dual awareness of
that oceanicness and how it is eternal
and that's how you both die before you
die and find out that there is no death
because that non-dual awareness is
eternally being colored by
experience
use your imagination get yourself out of
just this one creation design
use your imagination to envision
awareness being colored
across all of the other creation designs
eternally
the more you are focused on time past
and future the more you miss the now
the most precious thing there is it is
the only thing
it's all there is the eternal present is
the space
within which your whole life unfolds the
one factor that remains constant
life is now it is your only point of
access into the timeless and formless
realm of being
we talk a lot on the show about
unsubscribing
to time along with ego
they are the two biggest anchors holding
you back from god
realization
past and future only pale reflections of
the light
power and reality of the eternal present
their reality is borrowed from the now
the moment you grasp it there is a shift
in consciousness from mind
to being from time to presence
suddenly everything feels alive radiates
energy
emanates being
love it the reason why some people love
to engage in dangerous activities such
as mountain climbing car racing
is that it forces them into the now that
intensely alive state that is free of
time free of problems free of thinking
free of the burden
of the personality slipping away from
the present moment even for a second
may mean death
since ancient times spiritual masters of
all traditions have pointed to the now
as the key to the spiritual dimension
beautiful flowers that are not anxious
about tomorrow but live with ease
in the timeless now and are provided for
abundantly by god
nature is our greatest teacher
the whole essence of zen consists in
walking
along the razor's edge of now to be so
utterly so completely
present that no problem no suffering
nothing that is not who you are in your
essence can survive in you
in the now in the absence of time all
your problems dissolve
suffering needs time it cannot survive
in the now
and i love this from
rinzai zen so good
what at this moment is lacking
it's so simple ask yourself
that question and your family friends
co-workers people online at this moment
is lacking
once you begin to answer that question
with nothing it's just
indescribable perfection that's when
you're getting it
and then here's another version if not
now
when
the cons of zen are profound
love them so
mystic let's get that back into focus
here
so mystics and mysticism
in general
all right looks like this back in focus
are the
union with god the union
with the divine union with the absolute
that's what mystic and mysticism is all
about
and so you get to a union with the now
which is that god that absolute the
recognition
of that formlessness and form
recognizing that truly the eternity of
that
the sufi is the son of time present
and rumi says past and future veil god
from our sight burn up both of them with
fire
i love that one meister eckhart says
time is what keeps the light from
reaching us there is no greater obstacle
to
god than time that's so profound
step out of the time dimension as much
as possible in
everyday life
to that witnessing presence the still
observing presence itself
behind the content of your mind the
silent
watcher
the enlightened person's main focus of
attention
is always the now but they are still
peripherally aware of time
what is it that determines the quality
of your consciousness
your degree of presence
a state of consciousness totally free of
all negativity is possible
this is the liberated state to which all
spiritual teachings point
amen ultimately
there is only one problem the time-bound
mind
itself
presence is the key to freedom
you cannot be both unhappy and fully
present
in the now
as in happiness and the egoic separate
entity
are mutually exclusive positions
use your senses fully be where you are
look around this is a great practice
give this a go everyone
just look don't interpret see the light
shapes colors textures be aware
of the silent presence of each thing
be aware of the space that allows
everything to be
listen to the sounds don't judge them
listen to the silence
underneath the sounds touch something
anything and feel and acknowledge its
being
observe the rhythm of your breathing
feel the air flowing
in and out feel the life
energy inside your body allow
everything to be within and without
allow the isness of all things
move deeply into the now
such a good practice in essence you're
basically
just relaxing
and just being present
conscious of your breath
conscious of the proximal environment
understanding the sharedness of our
beingness
focus your attention on the now and tell
me what problem you have at this moment
love that one
create no more problems be truly fed up
with suffering
access the power of the now create no
more pain for
others no longer contaminate the
beautiful earth your inner space
and the collective human psyche with the
negativity of problem making
you will find it more effective to do
nothing
just stay centered in the now
the awakening of consciousness from the
dream of matter
form and separation the ending of time
we are breaking mind patterns that have
dominated human life for eons
mind patterns that have created
unimaginable suffering on a vast scale
unconsciousness insanity
ask yourself is there joy ease and
lightness
in what i am doing
how is always more important than what
give much more attention to the doing
than the result that you want to achieve
through it
completely accept what is you cannot
give your full attention to something
and at the same time resist it when you
act out of present moment awareness
whatever you do becomes imbued with a
sense of quality care and love
even the most simple action
non-attachment to the fruit of your
action is called karma yoga
yet on a deeper level you are already
complete and when you realize that there
is a playful joyous energy
behind what you do
childlike laughter of the infinite
child-like innocence child like bliss
child
like play childlike peace
everything is honored but nothing
matters forms are
born and die yet you are aware of the
eternal underneath the forms
you know that nothing real can be
threatened
you have succeeded already
love that one mind strategies for
avoiding the now
eventually presence becomes your
predominant state
continuous low level of unease
discontent boredom or nervousness a kind
of background static
such as the hum of an air conditioner
when it suddenly does
stop there is a sense of relief
thanks for tuning in to this everyone
super appreciate you
the best indicator of your level of
consciousness is how you deal with
life's challenges when they come
carl jung tells in one of his books of a
conversation he had with the native
american
chief who pointed out to him that in his
perception
most white people have tense faces
staring eyes in a cruel demeanor he said
they are always seeking something what
are they seeking the whites always want
something
they are always uneasy and restless we
don't know what they want
we think they are mad
that's much of modernity today
and much of indigeneity is asking that
question
and we've interviewed several of those
leaders on the program
and they ask that same question
in many ways it seems like it's
artificial general intelligence
something like that
in some sort of a decentralized
swarm orthogenic unilinear
style evolutionary
ascension towards this baton pass
from humans to this artificial general
intelligence
there's a lot more nuances there in that
metaverse
synthesis with things like
biotech and neurotech and
indistinguishable virtual realities and
the transcension hypothesis of going
inward as well as the
exploration of the cosmos but yeah agi
is going to be a massive part
and that that seems like what is being
sought after by modernity relentlessly
buddha taught that the root of suffering
is to be found in our constant wanting
and craving
monitor your mental emotional state
through self-observation
am i at ease at this moment if you get
the
inside right the outside will fall into
place
are you polluting the world or cleaning
up the mess
to complain is always non-acceptance of
what is
it invariably carries an unconscious
negative charge
leave the situation or accept it all
else is madness
no excuses no negativity no psychic
pollution
keep your inner space clear
only a surrendered person has spiritual
power
through surrender you will be free
internally of the situation
you may then find that the situation
changes
without any effort on your part you
are free i love that
it's a way effortless action
read the doubter ching by lao tza if you
haven't yet
the fact that everyone else is doing it
doesn't make it any less insane
time ego 40 hour work week the economic
machinery
it's no measure of good health and
flourishing to be
profoundly adjusted to a sick society
you reduce the present moment to a means
to an
end habitual waiter
small scale waiting
is like post office traffic jam
airports waiting for someone to arrive
to finish work and so on
whereas large scale waiting is waiting
for the next vacation for a better job
for the child to grow
up for a truly meaningful relationship
for success to make money
to be important to become enlightened it
is not uncommon for people to spend
their
whole life waiting to start living
are you a habitual waiter that's such a
good way to put it eckert
such a good way to put it it's like
completely ignoring
the now and that eternal presence to be
ruminating
in my next five minutes
of traffic or my next vacation
that kind of a thing
this greatly reduces the quality of your
life by making you lose the present
it is already whole complete and perfect
when you fully accept what you have got
you are grateful for what you have got
grateful for what is grateful for being
in gratitude for the
present moment and the fullness of life
now
is true prosperity
gratitude gratitude gratitude gratitude
gratitude
even if you do make millions you will
continue to experience the inner
condition of lack
deep down you will continue to feel
unfulfilled
how many more unfulfilled examples of
millionaires do we need
turn inward you won't abide in being and
so
feel the fullness of life now that alone
is true
prosperity
again it's about that that atama vichara
that self abiding
that's all right i wasn't waiting i was
just standing here enjoying myself
enjoy in myself when someone says sorry
to keep you waiting
the background static of perpetual
discontent
that's what the habitual waiter
experiences background static of
discontent
the only thing that is ultimately real
about your journey is the step that you
are taking at this moment
that's all there ever is
focus on the how the quality of your
consciousness at this moment
the journey into yourself
gain the world and lose your soul as
jesus puts it
the sooner you realize that your outer
purpose cannot give you lasting
fulfillment the better
you make your outer purpose subservient
to your inner purpose
and as you god realize it becomes a very
effortless action
for your outer purpose to just naturally
harmonically
unfold with the highest morality
the power of your presence your
consciousness liberated from thought
forms
deal with the past and dissolve it
through the power of your presence
you find yourself by coming into the
present
conscious presence that dissolves the
past
that is the transformative agent
love it all right the state of presence
try a little experiment close your eyes
and say to yourself i wonder what my
next thought is going to be
then become very alert and wait for the
next thought
be like a cat watching a mouse hole what
thought is going to come
out of the mouse hole try it now
some zen masters have been known to
creep up on their students from behind
and suddenly hit them with a stick
quite a shock if the student had been
fully present
he would have noticed the master coming
up from behind and stopped him or
stepped aside
but if he were hit that would mean he
was immersed in thought which is to say
absent unconscious
otherwise the mind will drag you along
like a wild
river
have you ever gazed up into the infinity
of space or truly listen to the sound of
a mountain stream in the forest
or to the song of a black bird at dusk
to become aware of such things
the mind needs to be still
that's such a good example and that's
when you actually see the hummingbird
that goes and
sticks its beak into the
flowers for nectar
the wider the time gap between
perception and
thought the more depth there is to you
as a human being
which is to say the more conscious you
are
being becomes conscious of itself that's
presence
god declares i am the alpha and the
omega
i am the living one timeless
which is also your home eternally
present in an unmanifested state of
oneness and perfection
again consciousness manifesting as form
just like consciousness manifests form
in dreams
so reality is recursive the process of
the macro level dream calls upon us
to dream during sleep which we do for a
third of our lives
so lila the divine game that god is
playing
consciousness is god essence expressing
itself in form
realize your own god essence as pure
consciousness
so lila is like the cosmic play the
divine play
that's anarchic that's creative it's
just an app
a play of the absolute
an infinite play and finding
piercing the veil and god realization
an infinite parable of the prodigal son
his father loves him more than before
the sun's state
has an added dimension of depth in that
parable of prodigal son
and all 8 billion
humans in this dream
creation design have their own unique
styles
of finding in the sufi metaphysic they
use the word
wadat al-wujud the unity of all finding
and so people have all these different
ways
of finding of finding god realization
piercing the veil
and that's the lila that's the cosmic
play the divine play
through you consciousness is awakening
out of its dream of identification with
form and withdrawing from form
when consciousness frees itself from its
identification with physical and mental
forms it becomes what we may call pure
or enlightened consciousness
or presence
the collective egoic mind is the most
dangerously insane and destructive
entity to ever
inhabit this planet
boom and we talk about that a lot on the
program that people in positions of
power across the planet that have a go
at consciousness
is our most upstream malady
the teacher and the taught together
create the teaching
the words are not the truth they only
point to it
silence is an even more potent carrier
of presence
listen to the silence wherever you are
is an easy and direct way of becoming
present
what is stillness other than presence
consciousness freed from
thought forms the living realization
of what we have been talking about
before abraham was i am
the realm of the timeless the dimension
of eternity
i am that i am no time here just
presence
exodus 3 14. second coming of christ is
a transformation of human consciousness
a shift from time to presence from
thinking to pure consciousness
there is no mine or yours in presence
presence is
one
ah
the inner body
in being subject and object merge into
one
being can be felt as the ever present i
am that is beyond name
and form
abide in that deeply rooted state is
enlightenment
is the truth that jesus says will make
you free
free from the illusion that you are
nothing more than your physical body and
your mind
illusion of the self
human race killed over 100 million
members of its own species in the 20th
century alone
again to transform that egoic
consciousness to non-dual consciousness
is paramount
above all observe your own mind
seek out the root of the insanity there
come to know that you are beyond the
outer form
inward journey ever more deeply into a
realm of great stillness and peace
yet also of great power and vibrant life
underneath your outer form you are
connected with something so vast
so immeasurable and sacred that it
cannot be conceived or spoken of
[Music]
you cannot stop thinking compulsive
thinking has become a collective disease
your whole sense of who you are is then
derived from mind activity
the one thing that truly matters
awareness of your deeper self
your invisible and indestructible
reality
to become conscious of being you need to
reclaim consciousness from the mind
the inner body lies at the threshold
between your form identity
and your essence identity your true
nature
never lose touch with it
so create that portal to the formless
and anchor that
in your day-to-day in the form
transformation is through the body not
away from it
all such teachings are signposts
pointing the way
back to the source it's the perennial
wisdoms
through the inner body you are
inseparably connected to this
unmanifested one life
birthless deathless eternally present
through the inner body
you are forever one with god
the key is to be in a state of permanent
connectedness with your
inner body to feel it all
times
you won't lose yourself in the external
world and you won't lose yourself in
your mind
no matter what happens on the outside
nothing can shake you anymore
this one's great the parable of the two
men who build a house one man builds it
on the sand without a foundation
and when the storms and floods come the
house is swept away
the other man digs deep until he reaches
the rock
then builds his house which is not swept
away by the floods and this is very much
like the parable of the prodigal son
which is if you go inward first you dig
deep and reach the rock
then you build your house and then that
does not get swept away by the floods
and it makes a wu-wei
effortless action easy outward and so
these two happen at the same time
in a non-dual but this is a dualistic
concession in explanation
attention is like a beam of light the
focused power of your consciousness
that transmutes everything into itself
where focus goes energy flows
grievance serves no purpose except to
strengthen a false
sense of self forgiveness is to offer no
resistance to life to allow life
to live through you
presence is pure consciousness
consciousness remembering its origin
and returning to the source
you recognize the truth when you hear it
the more consciousness you bring into
the body the stronger the immune system
becomes pragmatic
health and wellness benefits as well and
same thing with
your psychic immune system is greatly
enhanced as well
protects you from the negative mental
emotional force fields of others
by raising the frequency vibration of
your total energy field
anything that vibrates at a lower
frequency such as fear anger depression
doesn't enter your field of
consciousness anymore
because it passes right through you
flood your body with consciousness
let your attention run through the body
like a wave a few times from
feet to head and back again hold that
feeling for a few minutes
be intensely present during that time
and this is very similar to the
vipassana
it's also very similar to the white
skeleton meditation and the melting
butter meditation
again it's something that really
requires a deep
practice with focusing one's attention
and you can use a respiration to focus
your attention and to work that and then
do these body scans
where you run that attention and you can
even imagine a visual
white source light that is just
just illuminating those parts of your
body that you're scanning
and it feels like it just destroys the
pain
in the physical form and it feels
incredible
and so these body scanning meditation
practices are really incredible you can
look these up and
end up and implement them and practice
them
let the breath take you into the body
conscious breathing which is a powerful
meditation in its own right will
gradually put you in touch with the body
follow the breath with your attention as
it moves in and out of your body
the realization of oneness which is love
at the deepest level of being you are
one with all that is
portals into the unmanifested
we
[Music]
child childlike laughter of the infinite
hey hey
childlike laughter of the infinite hey
hey
okay
look at your surroundings for a few
minutes in a meditative way
without labeling them mentally and
continue to feel the inner body as you
do so
having access to that formless realm is
truly liberating
it frees you from bondage to form and
identification with
form it is life in its undifferentiated
state prior to its fragmentation into
multiplicity
deep stillness and peace
joy and intense aliveness you become
transparent to the light the pure
consciousness
that emanates from the source the
unmanifested is the source of chi
it lies halfway between the manifested
the world of form and the unmanifested
she is movement the unmanifested is
stillness absolute stillness gone beyond
to the source itself the unmanifested
she is the link between the unmanifested
and the physical universe
energy formless form
and it's fascinating with things like
the revelation with quantum mechanics
that we recognize that all is energy all
is
no thing and the greatest physicists
have been talking about this for a long
time
there is no matter
this singularity where the world
dissolves into the unmanifested
and the unmanifested takes on form as
the energy stream of
chi which then becomes the world this is
the point of
birth and death when your consciousness
is directed outward
mind and world arise when it is directed
inward it realizes its own source and
returns home into the unmanifested
when your consciousness comes back to
the manifested world
you reassume the form identity that you
temporarily relinquished
so basically it's an ebb and flow like
we talked about in our episodes from the
physical
to the absolute and so every time
you're going inward
you're in that absolute in that formless
and then every time you go outward when
somebody says your name
they ask for you to do something for
them
bring me the screwdriver that's when you
enter into the
physical into the form into your
identity with name
so this beautiful ebb and flow of
unmanifested to manifested
and the human as the portal
between the two
keep the portal open be conscious of the
unmanifested throughout your life
a deep sense of peace somewhere in the
background a stillness that never leaves
you
you become a bridge between the
unmanifested and the manifested between
god and the world
this is the state of connectedness with
the source that we call
enlightenment again it's just that
anchoring of that god realization
in your tantric path the sahaja samadhi
weaving it
into your daily activities you take a
journey
into the unmanifested every night when
you enter the phase of deep
dreamless sleep
so use your inner body as a portal
through which you
enter the unmanifested and keep that
portal open so that you stay connected
with the source at all times
perfect time
in the manifested are as inextricably
linked as the timeless now and the
unmanifested
again your body is that portal into the
formless
you feel the god essence in every
creature
every flower every stone and you realize
all that is
is holy this is why jesus
says in the gospel of thomas split a
piece of wood
i am there lift up a stone and you will
find me there
and that's why in the sufi metaphysics
they have the everywhere you look you
see
god's face
the stronger the feeling of separateness
the more you are bound to the manifested
to the world of separate forms the more
you are bound to the world of form
the harder and more impenetrable your
form identity becomes
the portal is closed and you are cut off
from the inner dimension the dimension
of depth
in the state of surrender your form
identity softens and becomes somewhat
transparent
as it were so the unmanifested can shine
through you
so it's like the overcast dissolves
every sound is born out of silence dies
back
into silence and during its lifespan is
surrounded by silence
silence enables the sound to be the
unmanifested is present
in this world as silence this is why it
has been said that nothing in this world
is so like god
as silence
silence without stillness within you
have entered the unmanifested
so the formless
is like the silence between the musical
notes
and the musical notes are like the form
again these great explain like i'm five
analogies
physicists tell us that the solidity of
matter is an illusion
seemingly solid matter is nearly 100
percent empty space
even inside every atom there is mostly
empty space
what is left is more like a vibrational
frequency more like a musical note
form is emptiness emptiness is form
buddhists have known for over 2 500
years
the essence of all things is emptiness
an empty fullness
everybody pays attention to the things
in space
but who pays attention to space itself
nothing space is the appearance of the
unmanifested as an externalized
phenomenon in a sense-perceived world
space has no existence although in
itself it has no existence it enables
everything else to exist
silence has no existence either nor does
the unmanifested
space and silence are two aspects of the
same thing
the same no thing stillness the
infinitely creative womb of all
existence
most humans are out of balance they know
the world or
think they do but they don't know god
nothing real can be threatened nothing
unreal
exists herein lies the peace of god
that's from a course in miracles
remain in conscious connection with the
unmanifested
you value love and deeply respect the
manifested and every life form
in it as an expression of the one life
beyond form you also know that every
form is destined to dissolve again
and that ultimately nothing out here
matters all that much
you have overcome the world in the words
of jesus or as the buddha put it you
have crossed
over to the other shore
love those
nothing could be more awe-inspiring and
majestic than the inconceivable vastness
and stillness of space
and yet what is it emptiness vast
emptiness
it is the body of god
two essential attributes of god infinity
and eternity
vom asi you are that i am that
we are that i and my father are one
john 10 30.
the ultimate purpose of the world lies
not within the world
but in transcendence of the world
if there were no illusion there would be
no enlightenment
you are here to enable the divine
purpose of the universe to unfold
that is how important you are
leela the divine play the cosmic
play
even if you have missed all the other
opportunities for spiritual realization
during your lifetime
one last portal will open up for you
immediately after the body has died
the tibetan book of the dead describes
it as the luminous splendor of the
colorless light of emptiness
most people carry too much residual
resistance too much fear too much
attachment to sensory experience too
much identification
with the manifested world so they see
the portal turn away in fear
and then lose consciousness their
presence
wasn't strong enough yet for conscious
immortality
you then realize that death is an
illusion just as your identification
with form was an illusion
the end of illusion that's all that
death is
enlightened relationships
[Music]
even a big part of the
challenge with figuring out how to
optimize
these exegesis that we do
is just the comfort in the
setup
you can see it a little bit from the one
shot
yeah so here's the camera that's
pointing downward
and here's the book that's angled on a
pillow
to make it simpler and then i'm flipping
this shot 180 degrees
it's just a fun process to figure out
how to optimally
do this and obviously we have
interviews happening tomorrow so i have
to move all the cameras back into
position
so it's not like we can just have this
as a dedicated setup
so just optimizing and figuring out that
process a little bit of
fun behind the scenes for everyone
it's always fun to connect with you guys
like that
all right
enlightened relationships
when i obtain this or am free of that
then i will be okay true salvation is
fulfillment
peace life in all its fullness
abiding presence to know god
your own innermost essence true
salvation is to know
yourself as an inseparable part of the
timeless and formless one life from
which
all that exists derives its being true
salvation is a state of freedom from
fear from suffering from a perceived
state of lack and
insufficiency and therefore from all
wanting
needing grasping and clinging it is
freedom from compulsive thinking from
negativity
and above all from past and future as a
psychological
need boom
you get there by realizing that you are
there already you find god the moment
you realize that you don't need to
seek god
only the ignorant seek what is already
there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
sufi metaphysic
love as a continuous state
is as yet very rare as rare as
conscious human beings
it is also easier to recognize the
source of negativity in your partner
than to see it in yourself
when you are together you feel whole the
feeling can become so intense that the
rest of the world fades into
insignificant
skins there is a neediness
and a clinging quality to that intensity
irresistible urge for union with the
opposite energy polarity
we talked about that in depth in the
walter russell the universal one
exegesis
to know yourself as the being underneath
the thinker the stillness underneath the
mental noise the love and joy underneath
the pain
is freedom salvation enlightenment
in the stillness of your presence you
can feel your own
formless and timeless reality as the
unmanifested life
that animates your physical form
you can then feel the same life deep
within
every other human and every other
creature you look beyond the veil of
form and separation
this is the realization of oneness this
is
love
what is god the eternal one life
underneath
all the forms of life what is love to
feel the presence of that one life deep
within yourself and within all creatures
to be it therefore all love
is the love of god
true communication is communion the
realization of oneness
which is love
the relationship then becomes your
sadhara
your spiritual practice if you observe
unconscious behavior in your partner
hold it
in the loving embrace of your knowing so
that you won't react
unconsciousness and knowing cannot
coexist for long
even if the knowing is only in the other
person and not
in the one who is acting out the
unconsciousness
the energy form that lies behind
hostility and attack
finds the presence of love absolutely
intolerable
it means being the knowing rather than
being the reaction in the judge
instead of fighting the darkness you
bring in the light no greater catalyst
for transformation exists
if you practice this your partner cannot
stay with you and remain unconscious
every challenge is actually a disguised
opportunity for salvation trauma to
treasure
if you are consistently or at least
predominantly present in your
relationship this will be the greatest
challenge for your partner
they will not be able to tolerate your
presence for very long and stay
unconscious
if they are ready they will walk through
the door that you open for them
and join you in that state if they are
not you will separate like oil and water
the light is too painful for someone who
wants to remain in darkness
all things vanish into the dao it alone
endures
the traditional god as the old testament
suggests
is a projection of the human mind
as a general rule the major obstacle for
men
tends to be the thinking mind and the
major obstacle for women the pain body
a victim identity is the belief that the
past is more powerful than the present
which is the opposite of the truth it is
the belief that other people
and what they did to you are responsible
for who you are now
for your emotional pain or your
inability to be your true self
you are responsible for your inner space
now nobody else is
and that the past cannot prevail against
the power of the now
it becomes a vortex of consciousness
that will draw on many others
it is perfectly possible for an
enlightened person if the need for the
male or female polarity is not met to
feel a sense of lack or incompleteness
on the outer level of his or her being
yet at the same time be totally complete
fulfilled and at peace within
yeah these are interesting because even
this one over here
about becoming a vortex of consciousness
that draws in many others is already
starting to happen
there are now you know dozens of people
that are reaching out
across our direct path videos and just
even directly to us and
we are being a mirror for their god
realization which is fascinating
and then over here on this one it's
interesting because there's a lot of
people now
including myself that have been
celibate for a while and been just
focused on their own piercing of the
veil their own
god realization and
experiencing satori now and
being enlightened is quite a
a fascinating sort of 24 7 bliss in
peace
that is it still has this component here
where you're kind of like well at some
point you're kind of wondering
well you know just a complete surrender
period right a complete surrender to the
indescribable
perfection that this is and so then
it is likely that whatever ends up
happening with a potential
partner and having children will unfold
and so just a complete surrender to that
because
it's not just myself but many other
people
have been finding that this is something
fascinating and it also
it also has some um perverse incentives
too
where people use their power
in order to um to fulfill those
quote like lower primal needs and so
your level of enlightenment your level
of non-duality is also clearly evident
with how you don't fall into the
unethical perverse incentives of that
dilemma
being an outsider to some extent someone
who does not fit in
with others or is rejected by them for
whatever reason makes life difficult
but it also places you at an advantage
as far as enlightenment is concerned
it takes you out of unconsciousness
almost by force
so being a misfit or being neuro-diverse
or neuro-atypical
is actually an advantage and this i very
much
found in my trajectory is constantly
being a misfit but also being joseph in
the code of many colors a synthesis at
the same time
so it was a fascinating having both of
those
and constantly being called by people
like oh you're
neuro-diverse you're neuro-atypical or
you're autistic
you know and all these different words
but that's why by 28 pierce the veil god
realization
because i just relentlessly pursued
truth and it yielded
and so that's usually what happens with
these
quote misfits neuro-diverse
neuro-atypical autistics this is
hardcore pursuit
of something like this what is the true
nature of reality relentless relentless
relentless and boom it pierces
can't do it for like you know an hour a
week
and think that it's gonna pierce you
know
as soon we'll have the vr pedagogies and
all these other types of things that
will sort of accelerate the
god realization process but
you know to see all of these different
faces
up the mountain to see all those
different paths and to be able to
connect all the different
waypoints as sign posts
into a lattice work
that's some real anchoring of the
non-duality
when you are enlightened there is one
relationship that you no longer have
the relationship with yourself once you
have given that
up all your other relationships will be
love relationships
beyond happiness and unhappiness there
is peace
when you live in complete acceptance of
what is which is the only sane way to
live
there is no good or bad in your life
anymore there is only a higher good
which includes the bad
forgive every moment allow it to be as
it is
then there will be no accumulation of
resentment that needs to be forgiven at
some later time
accept whatever comes to you woven in
the pattern
of your destiny for what could more
aptly fit your needs
marcus aurelius the ultimate
effect of all the evil and suffering in
the world
is that it will force humans into
realizing who they
are beyond name and form again it's that
pressure cooker
evil and suffering pressure cooker to
pierce the veil towards god realization
towards an enlightened civilization
it all serves humanity in this dream
you dissolve discord heal pain
dispel unconsciousness without doing
anything
simply by being and holding that
frequency of intense presence
most people are in love with their
particular life drama
their story is their identity the ego
runs their life
they have their whole sense of self
invested in it
what they fear and resist most is the
end of their drama
as long as they are their mind what they
fear and resist most is their own
awakening
when you live in complete acceptance of
what is
that is the end of all drama in your
life nobody can
even have an argument with you no matter
how hard he or she tries
you cannot have an argument with a fully
conscious person
just love how true that is we just
melt other people's anger
and frustration just with our conscious
presence
it's beautiful
in polymethy you know you have to be
able to know how to be
a ninja and a jedi you have to have a
strong lattice work
and high emotional intelligence along
with your high
spiritual intelligence so high
iq and eq go
well together with a high sq
no one who is at one with himself can
even conceive of conflict
a course in miracles
abiding presence an unchanging deep
stillness on
uncaused joy beyond good and bad this is
the joy of being
the peace of god
dissolution is needed for new growth to
happen one cannot exist without the
other
again something we deeply covered in
that universal one by
walter russell exegesis you can check
out
a constant flux of change
impermanence aneesha in poly
for change impermanence
a rhythmic balanced interchange
the buddha taught that even your
happiness is dukkha
suffering unsatisfactoriness don't
pursue an illusion for the rest of your
life
consumer society would collapse if
people became enlightened and no longer
sought to find their identity through
things the more you seek happiness in
this way
the more it will elude you nothing out
there will ever satisfy you except
temporarily and superficially
but you may need to experience many
delusions before you realize that truth
joy is uncaused and arises from within
as the joy of being
the inner state of peace the peace of
god your natural state
old testament i have seen everything
that is done
under the sun and behold all is vanity
in a striving after
wind a striving after wind
all that arises passes away this i know
no resistance to what is allow the
present moment to be
and accept the impermanent nature of all
things and conditions
thus i have found peace
to offer no resistance to life is to be
in a state of grace ease and lightness
when your inner dependency on form is
gone the general conditions of your life
the outer
forms tend to improve greatly life
flows with ease
negativity is a psychic pollutant there
is a deep link between the poisoning and
destruction of nature and the vast
negativity that is accumulated in the
collective human psyche
no other life form violates and poisons
the earth that sustains it
again something we've talked to many
indigenous
leaders about on our program as well
watch any plant or animal and let it
teach you
acceptance of what is surrender to the
now
let it teach you being let it teach you
integrity which means to be one
to be yourself to be real let it teach
you how to live and how to die and how
not to make living and dying into a
problem
all of these zen masters cats
and ducks peacefully they float along
at ease with themselves totally present
in the now
dignified and perfect as only a mindless
creature can be
when you have reached a certain degree
of presence you don't need negativity
anymore to tell you what is needed in
your life situation
but as long as negativity is there use
it use it as a kind
of signal that reminds you to be more
present
right that suffering is your drill
sergeant for awakening
that's was a good wisdom from bentino
massaro
negativity helpful signal
wake up get out of your mind
be present
instead of having a wall of resistance
inside you that gets constantly
and painfully hit by things that should
not be happening
let everything pass through you you
become invulnerable
that person no longer has the power to
control your inner state
you are then in your power not in
someone else's
nor are you run by your mind
uh
all right fam we're on the home stretch
the moment you completely accept your
non-peace
your non-peace becomes transmuted into
peace
anything you accept fully will get you
there will take you
into peace this is the miracle of
surrender
give me the best piece of meat you have
said the customer
and the butcher replied every piece of
meat i have is the best
there is no piece of meat here that is
not the best
and upon hearing this banzan became
enlightened
that's another one of those great
zen cones
when you accept what is every piece of
meat
every moment is the best that is
enlightenment
you abide in being unchanging timeless
deathless
and you are no longer dependent for
fulfillment or happiness on the outer
world of constantly fluctuating forms
compassion is the awareness of a deep
bond between yourself and all creatures
one of the most powerful spiritual
practices is to meditate deeply
on the mortality of all physical forms
including your own
this is called die before you die
nothing that was real ever died only
names forms and illusions
love it on the level of form you share
mortality and the precariousness of
existence
on the level of being you share eternal
radiant life
these are the two aspects of compassion
this is the peace of god
it has great healing and transformative
power
body and death are part of the same
illusion created by the egoic mode of
consciousness which has no awareness of
the source of life and sees itself as
separate and constantly under threat
perfect
the greatest insights
that has come out of modern physics
is that of the unity between the
observer and the observed
you can't separate the consciousness
from physicalism they are one
the form and formless are one
an infinite number of completely
different interpretations
completely different worlds every being
is a focal point of consciousness and
every such focal point creates its own
world
although all those worlds are
interconnected
in the coming age the lion shall lie
down with the lamb
when the majority of humans become free
of egoic delusion this interchange will
affect all of creation
you will literally inhabit a new world
it is a shift in planetary consciousness
the whole of creation is waiting for
humans to become enlightened
your primary task is awaken out of
identification with form
you can feel your roots in the
unmanifested you are in touch with
something infinitely greater than
any pleasure greater than any manifested
thing
you then don't need the world anymore
you don't even need it to be different
from the way it
is only those who have transcended the
world can bring about a better world
your peace is so vast and deep that
anything that is not
peace disappears into it as if it had
never existed
you teach through being through
demonstrating the peace of god
you become the light of the world an
emanation of pure consciousness
and so you eliminate suffering on the
level of cause you eliminate
eliminate unconsciousness from the world
the tantric path sahaja samadhi
you weave your enlightenment into the
social fabric
stay alert and very very present
enlightenment
your main purpose peace
your most precious gift to the world
the meaning of surrender
surrender is the simple but profound
wisdom of yielding
to rather than opposing the flow of life
again it's just surfing on the crest
of the wave
don't fight the wave relinquish
inner resistance to what is
surrender is perfectly compatible with
taking action
initiating change or achieving goals but
in the surrendered state a totally
different energy a different quality
flows into your doing
surrender reconnects you with the source
energy of being
and if your doing is infused with being
it becomes a joyful celebration of life
energy that takes you more deeply into
the now
surrendered action as more humans awaken
the word
work is going to disappear from our
vocabulary and perhaps a new word
will be created to replace it play
play play play play play play
to surrender is the most important thing
you can do
to bring about positive change
jesus said look at the lilies how they
grow they neither toil nor spin
you cannot be conscious and unhappy
conscious and
in negativity negativity unhappiness or
suffering in whatever form means
that there is resistance and resistance
is always unconscious
if you were conscious that is to say
totally present in the now all
negativity would dissolve almost
instantly
it could not survive in your presence
jesus in the sermon on the mount blessed
are the gentle
they shall have the earth for their
possession it is a silent but intense
presence that dissolves the unconscious
patterns of the mind
it is perfectly possible to say no
firmly and clearly to a person or to
walk away from a situation and be in a
state of complete inner non-resistance
at the same time
no that is free of all negativity
and so creates no further suffering
perfect
observe the attachment to your views and
opinions
feel the mental emotional energy behind
your need to be right
and make the other person wrong that's
the energy of the egoic
mind aka
the
left and right politics in the united
states
and the geopolitical polarization
enlightened politics
envision that
maximizing prosperity and abundance and
harmony and flourishing
around our planet with new sustainable
growth architectures
truly relinquish your identification
with a mental position
and so free yourself from your mind
you'll feel light clear and deeply at
peace
you have truly surrendered true
communication begins
don't resist the opponent's force yield
to overcome
woo way effortless action
anything bad that happens in your life
use it for enlightenment
trauma to treasure become an alchemist
transmute
suffering into consciousness disaster
into enlightenment
you are indestructible immortal it is
absolute certainty
that needs no external evidence or proof
from some secondary source
abide in the state of acceptance you
create no more negativity
no more suffering no more unhappiness
you then live in a state of
non-resistance
a state of grace and lightness free of
struggle
do not resist the pain allow it to be
there
surrender to the grief despair fear
loneliness or whatever form the
suffering takes
witness it without labeling it mentally
embrace it
then see how the miracle of surrender
transmutes deep suffering
into deep peace this is your crucifixion
let it become your resurrection and
ascension
you attract and manifest whatever
corresponds to your inner state
god realization is the most natural
thing there is
the amazing and incomprehensible fact is
that you
are not conscious of god and that's the
coolest
aspect about these creations is that we
have this veiling mechanism
where it's the most fascinating feature
where we can forget ourselves
we can have this amnesia of ourselves as
god and then we go through an amnesia or
a
self-remembering of our god realization
piercing the veil that veiling mechanism
is so fascinating
hide and seek
forcing you into surrender into death
forcing you to become as nothing to
become as god because god too
is no thing
enlightenment means choosing to dwell in
the state of presence rather than in
time
it means saying yes to what is you then
don't need
pain anymore how much more time do you
think you will need before you are able
to say i will create no more pain
no more suffering how much more pain do
you need before you can make that choice
time and pain are inseparable
the suffering thus created will
eventually force you
out of your unconscious state
that's the drill sergeant suffering
for enlightenment presence is the key
the now is the key
how will i know when i have surrendered
when you no longer need to ask the
question
boom that's all folks
and in the acknowledgements to the
greatest guru of all
life love that one and it was
interesting learning about eckert here
that when he was 29 he had his profound
inner transformation which radically
changed the course of his life
and i had mine when i'm 28 which is
super fascinating and aligned
and then also this awakening consists
in transcending our ego based state of
consciousness
this is a prerequisite not only for
personal happiness
but also for ending the violent conflict
endemic on our planet
again so if you want world peace
not just
not just the
personal god realization of
that well of honey
that non-duality but also on a planetary
level to get
world peace the most important thing we
can do is pierce the veil the most
important thing we can do is god realize
the most important thing we can do is
pay attention
deeply to things like the power of now
pay attention to the perennial wisdoms
across the spiritual mystic traditions
again they are just the different faces
and the different paths with different
signposts
to the same one end
and i'm really looking forward to
deploying that visual
soon that we're working on making which
is
again aiming to make it even more
explain like i'm five four people the
nature of reality
and the nature of people like eckhart
tolle who are
such a good synthesis of the different
perennial spiritual wisdoms and
traditions
and like ourselves and like our show as
well
and that's when you really get there
that's when you really get to the
essence
of the perfection that this already is
when you've really looked at all these
different faces to the mountain and
you've looked at all these different
paths and all these different
signposts and you see the one
end and you are the one and you become
the one
end and then you like a vortex
end up gravitating others towards their
god realization
as well
so gorgeous
i hope this exegesis of the power of now
has brought you tremendous value
please like the video if you haven't yet
subscribe
also let me know how you feel in the
comments below
with some of your thoughts would love to
hear from you
and check out eckertoli's website the
links in the bio below
also a bunch of our notes are in the bio
below
of our key highlights so you can
leverage those as you'd like
and also the book link to the power of
now
is down there as well for purchase
highly recommend checking out it's super
short
super easy to read and super fun so go
and give that a check out
and that's all
thank you so much for tuning in i love
you very much
this is just perfect
it's just perfect
you